[Music]
and use protection news oh I missed use
protection news - oh yeah submitted by
fine china
Oh what's that mean back plates a new
app allows Chinese citizens to hire a
personal bodyguard for as little as $10
an hour doll hairs
yeah bars pluck it off the doll didn't
we do an article where you can hire like
a goon oh yeah Chinese good not for ten
bucks so you know Chinese people are
[ __ ] crazy they'll hire like $10 okay
go jump in the river and just [ __ ]
just [ __ ] up their lives crazy far crazy
yeah cuz my friends do like stunt work
in China and they said like over there
they'll work for food like like the guys
out there will just say I'll come on set
and I'll do start work and I'll fall
I'll break my leg whatever you compete
with that
just give me food just give me two
dumplings and I'll break my leg free
unless they just have a burning passion
for and all they just cares about
getting food and not money I think I'm
just trying to think about like why they
would not take anyway and you thought
passion for me because I think out here
you know we we have like a place to live
we have our parents probably take care
we can't play like passion first what is
the meaning of life yeah you know out
there it's like any food survival yeah
we have friends if someone heard me is
like a ten dollar bodyguard and they're
like oh we want you to protect us while
we go chance for a hundred billion
dollars in the ghetto us there we're
like mm no that's not enough yeah
because you're Gina from the US that's
ten bowls of noodles that's if you think
about it that's ten bowls of noodles
that's like so if you eat three square
meals a day that's like two days with
the food at least like like poor to
accept this job but if you're that poor
you can't be a big-ass bodyguard I know
you're like very pure on the ship foods
I can't detecting you the work if you're
from northern China
seven feet although oh you know what
great but then but then because it's so
cheap you could have an army of them no
power numbers yeah it's like it's like
little ants against a scorpion just get
a hundred of them
honey cans can do a lot of [ __ ] do
your [ __ ] robot dance interface I
didn't know I'd be spineless like you if
she paid me ten bucks to be her
bodyguard so let's go beat up Gina oh
hey Gina if you give me 20 bucks I'll go
beat her up I'll come back to you give
me 30 bucks to go [ __ ] her up no team in
the world fall we'll both go the game oh
yeah and then you're extorting people
[Music]
order it's awesome yeah so this Chinese
app it's called gin and juice Jimmy wait
China
genuine yeah stop saying you can hire
bodyguard from ten to thirty dollars an
hour download over to the power an hours
Wow I want to download this right now
you know what that's kind of the same
price here
what well not a bodyguard bodyguard like
a bouncer that's less than minimum wage
if you have an armored car it's anywhere
from fifteen to thirty dollars an hour
yeah that's more than minimum wage
because they're ten dollars they can buy
ten noodles so they're ten dollars like
our $100 an hour
I suppose because our noodles are what
like five the ten bucks yeah yeah so
these bodyguards are expected to
undertake etiquette lessons
oh good okay listens in China you never
believe like you only blow out your
burgers on the left side of the road or
not the right side of the road I
no etiquette in China like went together
it doesn't match what is that I believe
a teacher not the [ __ ] on the floor your
clients house you could all be pee in
glass bottles not plastic you know what
really sucks is like classy Chinese
people that have been classy for a long
time having fun
we know you exist out there they're just
a minor party sorry but it's just you
guys are getting overshadowed right now
yeah and so the bodyguards are also
gonna be required to wear uniforms and
they're saying that this app has unified
more than 50 thousand security staff
members and 47 companies in the city and
so they're gonna be able to have their
availability on the app in real time for
people for clients to like pick and
choose don't I wanted to be like a
tinder swipe mm-hmm you know and yet
they're like the all their stats and
[ __ ] how many fights they've won too
small too weak you what if you hire your
own goons to commit crime and they don't
even know like this is you're going in
there to do something today or like I
don't know like you're moving stolen
merchandise and you need body cards so I
don't know yeah I'd like to build a
relationship with my bodyguards like I
don't want to just meet this guy and
then okay right now holds a gun to your
head you're like I don't care yeah like
it's only $10 yeah I don't care you know
it's kind of they're getting paid really
little to you their life yeah I want a
friendship with my bodyguard I want Lane
I want something mm-hmm like let me know
your children your family all that stuff
so then if you turn your back on me
exactly like warlord 101 always have to
know their family yeah you got I want to
invest it I mean each other right like
you know because there's accountability
I don't want to be a stranger yeah let's
get to know each other I will point in
your life do you think you would need
some but a hire a bodyguard when I don't
want to fight myself anymore whenever
I'm in Australia right yourself I mean
like I don't want
fighting myself anymore when I was in
Australia I [ __ ] well so I was doing
like a meet and greet and then they sent
these two girls that were [ __ ] like
teenagers to like be your bodyguard know
to guide me or be my whatever assistance
to go to the club and then I was sitting
outside we're waiting for the car and
they see their friends this group of
teenagers like early 20s maybe like and
they all [ __ ] bombarded me I was like
oh my god did you grab my boot I will
[ __ ] kill you guys right now like
that's the fans like dude that's [ __ ]
up then like the two girls I was like
what the [ __ ] are you doing you know
like an ass supposed to do that [ __ ] so
I gave it wasa call afterwards I was
like this is not cool dude like you're
[ __ ] oh okay that's why I need buddy
words it's really hard yeah damn that's
uh oh yeah you know what's crazy I was
gonna say something else but another
thought came into my head yeah you know
fighter you interrupted yourself you
know fighters have bodyguards because
people always want to fight them yeah so
like boxers professional boxers UFC
fighter whatever like reports people
just anyways all the time oh yeah I
[ __ ] I wanted I knocked out McGregor
like people want to say that the bar
fight with that [ __ ] and I knocked him
out he lost a bet that's so stupid
so then the bodyguards needs to like
constantly be there not cuz they can't
fight their own fights why would they
fight for free if they get paid exactly
millions - hmm yes sir using this app
would work here in America no did you
see already - Criminal Minds what they
already did yeah
they formed a gang in like two minutes I
didn't do nothing no chapo I just said I
wouldn't do it I also thought there's
too many laws here like yeah in China a
big dick people yeah they could just
think of an app and they could just
immediately do it that's what I'm saying
we should go to China and make an app
that's like tinder but for people who
want to fight you know you can do it add
ginger tinder but for people who want to
fight I don't have to go to China you
can start the app here and you and then
really soon China tinder but for good I
want to fight yeah
gender and rumbler a Rambler oh go
hmm and then you can write like a 1 out
of 10 like tonight and eat the [ __ ] me
I'm in the hospital my ears are bleeding
or one out of ten you tried to put it in
my butthole you know like he can just
rain people I rape
great great great oh oh that's cool like
they'll be [ __ ] dope like what if you
just want to go like easy sparring or a
hardcore sport it's like finding a
pickup game in basketball that creates
so many jobs cuz then now you can rent
out your place or your establishment to
host these fights yeah and now
everyone's making money that I would
that would be a lot better because
there's so many aggressive guys out
there that just want to look for fights
but now they can go on this app people
that want to fight I mean everyone's
gonna choose a little they're gonna
swipe right on the little nerdy dude
they can oh man [ __ ] him up but he turns
out he's a [ __ ] kung fu master yeah
killer
let me [ __ ] sick the disclaimer into
this claimer it will say like we have we
have no responsibility for anything that
happens to you we don't but we do have
responsibility testing for diseases and
weapons I don't control that yeah yeah
cuz you know on um this martial art form
like people that are part of it they go
oh let's do a spar meet up and then like
guys would just train together like oh
I'm gonna be in Southern California
let's go to the UFC gym and then people
meet up and train together and stuff
well be then will be the new UFC but
we'll be you are see you Rumble yeah
United Rumble cherishes championships
[ __ ] generation do that's a good idea
let's make it cover it you watch someone
already made it hey guys would you think
of that video I know you loved it so
make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos check it out up here
[Music]